what we're going to do in this video is
calculate a typical measure of how well
the actual data points agree with a
model in this case a linear model and
there's several names for it we could
consider this to be the standard
deviation of the residuals and that's
essentially what we're going to
calculate you could also call it the
root mean square error and you'll see
why it's called this because this really
describes how we calculate it
so we're going to do is look at the
residuals for each of these points and
then we're going to find the standard
deviation of them so just as a bit of
review the ith residual
is going to be equal to
the
y-value for a given x minus the
predicted y value for a given x now when
i say y-hat right over here this just
says what would the linear regression
predict for a given x and this is the
actual y for given x so for example and
we've done this in other videos this is
all review the residual here when x is
equal to 1
we have y is equal to 1 but what was
predicted by the model is 2.5 times 1
minus 2 which is 0.5 so 1
minus 0.5 so this residual here
this residual is equal to 1 minus 0.5
which is equal to 0.5 and it's a
positive 0.5 and if the actual point is
above the model you are going to have a
positive residual
now the residual
over here
you also have the actual point being
higher than the model
so this is also going to be a positive
residual and once again when x is equal
to 3 the actual y is 6
the predicted y is 2.5 times 3 which is
7.5 minus 2 which is 5.5 so you have 6
minus 5.5 so here i'll write residual is
equal to 6 minus 5.5
which is equal to
0.5 so once again you have a positive
residual
now for
this point that sits right on the model
the actual is the predicted the act when
x is two the actual is three and what
was predicted by the model is three so
the residual here is equal to the actual
is three and the predicted is three so
it's equal to zero
and then last but not least you have
this data point
where the residual is going to be the
actual when x is equal to 2
is 2
minus the predicted well when x is equal
to 2 you have 2.5 times 2 which is equal
to
5 minus 2 is equal to 3. so 2 minus 3 is
equal to negative 1.
and so when your actual is below your
regression line you're going to have a
negative residual so this is going to be
negative 1 right over there
now we can calculate the standard
deviation of the residuals we're going
to take this first residual which is 0.5
and we're going to square it we're going
to add it to the second residual right
over here i'll use this blue with this
teal color that's zero
i'm gonna square that
then we have
this third residual which is negative 1.
so plus
negative 1 squared and then finally we
have that fourth residual which is 0.5
squared 0.5
squared
so once again we took each of the
residuals the which you could view as
the distance between the points and what
the model would predict we are squaring
them when you take a typical standard
deviation you're taking the distance
between a point and the mean here we're
taking the distance between a point and
what the model would have predicted but
we're squaring each of those residuals
and adding them all up together
and just like we do with the sample
standard deviation we are now going to
divide by
one less than the number of residuals we
just squared and added so we have four
residuals we're gonna divide by four
minus one
which is equal to of course
three
you could view this part as a mean of
the squared errors and now we're going
to take the square root of it
so let's see this is going to be equal
to
square root of
this is 0.25 0.25
this is just 0.
this is going to be positive 1
and then this 0.5 squared is going to be
0.25
all of that over 3.
now this numerator is going to be 1.5
over
3.
so this is going to be equal to 1.5 is
exactly half of three so we could say
this is equal to the square root
of one half this is one over the square
root of two one
divided by
the square root of two
which gets us 2.
so if we round to the nearest
thousandths it's roughly
0.707
so approximately 0.707
and if you wanted to visualize that one
standard deviation of the residuals
below the line would look like this
and one standard deviation above the
line for any given x value would go one
standard deviation of the residuals
above it
it would look something like that
and this is obviously just a hand-drawn
approximation but you do see that this
does seem to be roughly indicative of
the typical residual
now it's worth noting sometimes people
will say it's the average residual and
it depends how you think about the word
average because we are squaring the
residuals so outliers things that are
really far from the line when you square
it are going to have disproportionate
impact here if you didn't want to have
that behavior we could have done
something like find the mean of the
absolute residuals that actually in some
ways would have been a simpler one but
this is a standard way of people trying
to figure out how much a model disagrees
with the actual data and so you can
imagine the lower this number is
the better the fit of the model